The Siberian Family Who Didn’t See Another
Human for Over 40 years
To this day, the Siberian wilderness is still
one of the most isolated places in the world.
Known as the Siberian taiga (meaning “forest”
in Russian), its harsh, cold climate greatly
discourages human habitation.
Its steep hills and difficult terrain makes
it nearly impossible to travel through it,
much less live there.
It’s filled with pine and birch trees, nearly
undisturbed by humans for centuries.
Bears and red foxes wander through the forest
during the day, while wolves hunt at night.
It’s freezing cold with the average mean
yearly temperature at negative five degrees
Celsius.
Stretching east to west, from the Atlantic
Ocean across the continent to the Mediterranean,
and extending up north to the Mongolian Arctic
border, the Siberian taiga is the largest
of Earth’s nearly uninhabited wilderness.
Nearly five million square miles of barren
land sparsely populated by a few towns containing
only a few thousand people.
In 1978, a team of Russian geologists were
sent to explore the deepest, most isolated
part of this region.
Forest and wilderness that, at the time, have
been barely touched by human hands.
Traveling there via helicopter, from high
above the taiga, they spotted something that
seemed quite unusual- a clearing with a garden,
clear evidence of human life.
This seemed nearly impossible to the geologists.
They were nearly 150 miles from the nearest
human settlement.
Upon landing, the geologists knew they had
to investigate, despite their trepidation.
One of the geologists, Galina Pismenskaya,
said later that they had “put gifts in our
packs for our prospective friends,” but
also checked “the pistol that hung at my
side.”
They continued on and found more signs of
human inhabitants- a wooden staff, a log bridge
across a stream, more gardens, until they
saw a hut.
They approached the hut with caution.
Finally, the makeshift door creaked open and
out stepped an old man with tattered clothing
and an unkempt long beard.
Despite having “fear in his eyes”, the
old man said very softly to his visitors,
“Well, since you have traveled this far,
you might as well come in.”
As the geologists entered, what they saw astonished
them.
The dwelling was something out of history
books- tree stumps holding up the foundation,
floor made out of potato peels and pine-nut
shells, everything covered in filth.
As they looked closer in the dim-lit, one
room shack, they saw this was a home for a
family of five, a father and four children,
two of which began crying uncontrollably at
the sight of humans unknown to them.
As the geologists said,
The silence was suddenly broken by sobs and
lamentations.
Only then did we see the silhouettes of two
women.
One was in hysterics, praying: ‘This is
for our sins, our sins.’
The other, keeping behind a post… sank slowly
to the floor.
The light from the little window fell on her
wide, terrified eyes, and we realized we had
to get out of there as quickly as possible.
Karp Lykov, the old man, once lived in a populated
part of Russia.
He was a member of a fundamentalist Russian
Orthodox sect known as the Old Believers,
called this because their worship style hasn’t
changed since the 17th century.
Old Believers had been persecuted in Russia
for centuries, even before the Soviets took
over.
Dating back to Peter the Great’s reign in
the late 17th and early 18th centuries, Old
Believers, who customarily wore beards, were
forced to pay a tax on their facial hair.
When the Soviets took over, Karp thought it
was time to retreat to sparsely populated
towns that dotted Siberia.
One day, in 1936, while working the fields
with his brother near their village, a Communist
guard came by and shot his brother right in
front of him.
Karp immediately grabbed his family (which,
at the time, only consisted of his wife, his
son Savin, and his 2-year old daughter Natalia)
and disappeared into the dark Siberian wilderness.
Karp and his wife, Akulina, had two more children
in the wild, Dmitry and Agafia, who before
they met the Russian geologists, had never
seen another human besides their own family.
Everything they knew of civilization came
from their parents.
They were taught how to read and write with
the help of an old family Bible.
They knew nothing of the world past 1936,
including even the existence of World War
II or the Cold War.
Every member of the family had to learn how
to provide for themselves using only the resources
found within the wilderness.
As the children grew, they became the hunters
and gatherers.
Dmitry, for example, learned how to kill animals
without guns or bows.
He did this by digging traps and chasing the
animals until they collapsed from exhaustion.
Times became even tougher for the family when
Akulina passed away in 1961 (approximately)
from starvation.
Now, it was just a father and four children
struggling to survive.
Realizing how traumatic this must be for the
kids, having never met another human before,
the geologists retreated out of the hut and
set up camp a little ways away.
Soon, the family came out and approached the
scientists, still scared but curious.
At first, they refused everything given to
them by the geologists, including clothes,
food, and bread (Karp explained that his youngest
children had never even seen bread, much less
tasted it).
Soon, the family and the geologists formed
a bond.
The geologists told them about what they’d
missed in the world since 1936 and showed
them modern innovations like cellophane (“Lord,
what have they thought up—it is glass, but
it crumples!”, exclaimed Karp) and television
(which scared and enthralled them at the same
time).
In turn, the family showed the geologists
how to survive in the Siberian taiga, including
how to grow crops in such harsh conditions.
The geologists continued to survey the wilderness,
co-existing with the family, for several years.
On several occasions, the scientists tried
to convince the family to move back to civilization,
but they refused.
Eventually, though, the years of survival
in harsh terrain caught up with them.
In the fall of 1981, three of the four children
(Dmitry, Natalia, and Savin) passed away within
several days of another, two from kidney failure
and one from pneumonia.
The geologists offered to transport the sick
members of the family to a hospital, but their
offer was staunchly refused.
After the death of the three, the geologists
once again tried to convince Karp, now a man
in his late 80s, and his youngest daughter,
Agafia, to move in with relatives in a village
150 miles away.
They still refused.
On February 16th, 1988, exactly 27 years to
the day after his wife, Karp passed away in
his sleep, leaving only Agafia as the surviving
member of the family.
Insisting on staying, Agafia, as far as I
could dig up, to this day now in her 70s,
still lives high in the mountains of the Siberian
taiga.
Alone.